cette fois-ci et bien c'est bien un vote
sur l'amendement qui a été défendu tout
à l'heure par Jean-François Husson le
rapporteur général de la commission des
finances et qui a été consignée par de
nombreux sénateurs de droite dont Bruno
Retailleau pour appeler là encore à
réfléchir à une part de capitalisation
dans notre système de retraite par
répartition on va voir le comment va se
dérouler ce vote cela risque d'être
intéressant on va voir comment vont se
partager et bien les sénateurs de droite
qui est plus proche de la position de la
Commission et ce et bien qui sont plutôt
bien sur la ligne de Bruno Retailleau on
va tout de suite entendre le vote dans
un instant
344 exprimés 289 pour 173 contre 126 le
Sénat a adopté et par con bref
conséquences les autres amendements
tombent
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]